bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht ist eines aus berlin
zugeschaltet gut mit vollem recht guten
abend wenn man sich ansieht was für ein
merchandising bei diesen nazi konzerten
betrieben wird zum beispiel auch mit t
shirts auf denen dann steht ilove adolf
warum muss der rechtsstaat so etwas
zulassen kann man das nicht verbieten
es muss genau geprüft werden ob
verfassungsfeindliche inhalte
volksverhetzung auf solchen t shirts
tassen oder was auch immer verkauft wird
zu sehen sind und dann kann
eingeschritten werden aber da ist die
hürde schon sehr hoch und wird damit
auch sehr viel geld verdient ein teil
dieses geldes sagt der verfassungsschutz
beobachtet gibt auch an waffenkäufe und
nun wollen sie ja mit ihrem neuen
massnahmenpaket waffen in deutschland
stärker regulieren aber kommt man damit
den ganzen illegalen waffen die auch von
rechtsextremen gehortet werden überhaupt
bei also wichtig ist dass extremisten
keine waffen in die hände bekommen und
wo der staat möglichkeiten hat dass es
eben auch entsprechend zu regeln ist und
deswegen wollen wir das
bevor eine waffenerlaubnis erteilt wird
und eine waffe eben dann geführt werden
kann dass eine regelanfrage beim
verfassungsschutz durchgeführt wird weil
das ist die möglichkeiten die wir haben
aber darüber hinaus muss natürlich durch
hausdurchsuchung durch verfolgung auch
darauf geachtet werden wo illegale
waffen gehortet werden und diese auch
aufgespürt naja zumal jetzt nazis
tatsächlich terroristische absichten
haben ja auch nicht offen kommunizieren
sondern in anderen bereichen des netzes
unterwegs sind und da auch nah an der
organisierten kriminalität
also da hilft keine verfassungsschutz
abfrage im zweifelsfalle nicht das ist
eine möglichkeit wie gesagt den
verfolgungsdruck erhöhen zu
kontrollieren
wir haben die hier verschiedene
gruppierungen sehr genau im blick das
ist ein weiterer baustein
wir müssen die gesamten möglichkeiten
nutzen und die verschärfung des
waffenrechts ist eine der möglichkeiten
stichwort internet auch da soll schärfer
vorgegangen werden also zb das facebook
und andere plattformen strafbares selber
direkt auch an strafverfolgungsbehörden
melden
aber dann muss es ja auch bearbeitet
werden die staatsanwälte und gerichte
sind ja jetzt schon überlassen
also erstmal ist wichtig dass die
ermittlungsbehörden die informationen
bekommen ip adressen um dann eben auch
solche nach volksverhetzung oder
morddrohungen nachgehen zu können
und deswegen ist diese meldung so
wichtig und ja es ist wichtig dass dann
auch die entsprechende personelle
ausstattung da ist deswegen wollen wir
dass diese meldungen an eine zentrale
stelle beim bka gemeldet werden und dort
eben auch personell aufgestockt wird und
wenn die entsprechenden mitteln durch
das parlament zur verfügung gestellt
werden dann ist das auch möglich aber
das gehört dazu
nur gesetze zu verschärfen ohne die
personelle ausstattung da wären wir
schlecht beraten was stellen sie denn da
konkreten aussicht einige hundert oder
wie viele staatsanwälte und ermittler
wird man da zusätzlich brauchen also wir
gehen schon davon aus dass mehrere
hundert zusätzliche stellen beim bka
erforderlich sind um eben wie gesagt
eine solche zentrale stelle und weitere
aufgaben wahrnehmen zu können es bringt
nichts
gesetze zu verschärfen ohne dann später
auch die entsprechenden ermittlungen
durchführen zu können
es geht ja auch darum dass dann in der
praxis umzusetzen sie sprachen gerade
von ip adressen von leuten die dann zum
beispiel drohungen ins netz stellen an
sie heranzukommen ist ziemlich schwierig
sei es technisch weil die server gar
nicht in deutschland sind aber auch
juristisch bleiben das ja vor kurzem
gesehen bei dem verfahren das renate
künast angestrengt hatte um an nutzer
daten heranzukommen das wurde
abgeschmettert stichwort
meinungsfreiheit
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass diese
daten schnell beim bka landen damit
schnell ermittelt werden und diese
ip-adresse nicht verloren gehen und die
plattformen sind plattformbetreiber sind
heute schon nach dem netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz verpflichtet
strafbare inhalte die gemeldet werden zu
sperren oder zu löschen
und in zukunft kommt eben diese
meldepflicht hinzu damit schnell
reagiert werden kann bevor daten
verloren gehen das ist der richtige
ansatzpunkt es muss schnell gehen aber
was strafbar ist es dann ja auch unter
pratt aktions sache also vieles was ja
auch im bereich beleidigungen das geht
jetzt über volksverhetzung steht quasi
neben volksverhetzung oder morddrohungen
die eindeutig sind beleidigungen werden
von gerichten offenbar sehr großzügig
ausgelegt also jeder der schon mal
solche beleidigungen netz erhalten hat
weiß wie schwer das ist dagegen
tatsächlich vorzugehen
ja es ist wichtig dass
angezeigt wird das gemeldet wird
ansonsten kann überhaupt nicht
nachgegangen werden und deswegen wollen
wir es auch auf schwerste
straftatbestände erstmal beschränken
nämlich auf volksverhetzung und motto
das ist relativ einfach zu
identifizieren
und wenn die meldung am beim bka
eingegangen ist kann ja nochmal geprüft
werden ob dieser relevanten tatbestand
erfüllt ist damit dann die
ermittlungsbehörden weiter arbeiten
können das ist der weg den wir uns
vorstellen die meldung über die
plattform bka und dann an die
ermittlungsbehörden aber das meiste was
im netz zu lesen ist sind keine
konkreten morddrohungen sondern sind
üble beleidigungen und dagegen hilft das
alles ja noch nicht also ich lese auch
ganz derbe um ganz üble beleidigungen
und volksverhetzung und auch
morddrohungen also da gibt es genug
leider zu sehen und leider zu vermerken
und deswegen muss eine klare ansage
gemacht werden dass das was im analogen
leben im normalen leben gilt dass die
meinungsfreiheit da aufhört wo
strafrecht beginnt dass genau das auch
im netz gilt es ist momentan so eine
vorstellung das ist ein rechtsfreier
raum das dürfen wir nicht länger
akzeptieren
dann muss der staat eben auch sagen wo
die grenze ist sagt er und es erst jetzt
ministerin ich danke für das interview